look at me and tell me what you see what
you see is a dwarf I had been born a
peasant they might have left me out in
the woods to die alas I was born a
Lannister of Casterly Rock things are
expected of me I'm dr. Ali Mattu
cognitive behavioral therapist and I'm
here today in collaboration with HBO to
offer my take on themes of mental health
in their shows never forget what you are
the rest of the world we're not married
like Obama you can never be used an edge
today we're focusing on depression
through the lens of Tyrion Lannister and
Game of Thrones
[Music]
anhedonia is a core symptom of
depression and it's what happens when
you no longer experience joy or pleasure
in the things that usually gave you joy
or pleasure
it's apps any motivation you have you
seem rather drunk usually the first
thing people do when they might be
experiencing anhedonia is just to try
more of the kind of stuff that they
enjoy to try to feel something but that
usually doesn't work what you need is to
use that anhedonia and try to understand
what changes you might need to make in
your life to get you moving in a
direction that you want to be in I'd
given up on life until Varys convinced
me you might be worth living for you
chop off my head well my final day is
what interesting I'm going to advise me
what I like to ask my patients is to
imagine your 100th birthday who's there
what stories are they sharing about your
relationship about the achievements that
you've made in your life
what I love about Tyrion is his story is
about connecting with the larger purpose
doing what's best for Westeros owning
who he is and the unique ways he can
help others we'll never know if Tyrion
was struggling with a mental illness but
whatever he was dealing with didn't get
in the way of him being a hero and
that's true for all of us no matter what
you're experiencing it doesn't have to
get in the way of living the life you
want to live that's my take for the day
I'm doctor my two
[Music]
you